les urgences des hôpitaux pédiatriques
ontariens débordent une crise sans
précédent aux yeux du médecin hygiéniste
en chef
je recommande que tous les Ontariens pas
seulement les plus vulnérables portent
le masque à l'intérieur dans les
endroits publics dans la Ville Reine
plusieurs auraient déjà emboîté le pas
que dans les dernières semaines à
Toronto on voit pas mal de plus de
masques que il y a quelques semaines
auparavant alors je pense que les gens
ont commencé à saisir le message dans un
tweet diffusé dimanche le Collège des
médecins du Québec proposait la même
chose avec la montée inquiétante des cas
de virus respiratoires chez les enfants
et le débordement des urgences
pédiatriques le Collège des médecins est
recommandé à nouveau le port du masque
dans les lieux publics une mesure qui
reflète l'ampleur de la crise vécue par
les hôpitaux pédiatriques c'est une
crise parce que nous avons un tsunami
d'infection virale respiratoire un
tsunami qui force le report de certaines
chirurgies on fait déjà du délestage
qui se font soit annulées ou reportées
il appuie donc l'obligation de porter le
masque à l'intérieur dans les lieux
publics mais l'idée rebute bien des
citoyens c'est bon là il y a plus trop
de contamination etc donc je pense que
on a assez supporté les masques
supporter
puis la majorité de porte pas enfin que
moi non plus puis je pense que c'est du
carré la santé publique et le ministère
de la Santé du Québec se contente pour
l'instant de faire appel au bon jugement
des citoyens à l'évidence personne ne
semble trop pressé d'imposer à nouveau
le port du masque ici David gentil
Radio-Canada MONT